ربما كنت تعتقد أن يوم الانتخابات كان
قبل ستة أسابيع ،
فأنت تعلم عندما فاز جو بايدن بـ
81 مليون صوت غير مسبوق
مما منحه فوزًا جامعيًا انتخابيًا
من 306 إلى 232
ولكن تبين اليوم أنها الانتخابات الحقيقية
فيما يتعلق بالدستور
عندما يكون 538 عضوًا من
تلتقي الكلية الانتخابية في
ولاياتهم للتصديق على أصوات ولايتهم.
الديماغوجي
منذ أن أصبح رئيسًا
لم ينجح تمامًا بهذه الطريقة التي ترى
أن الدستور لا يذكر
الأحزاب السياسية
ولكن مع ظهورها حتى جيمس ماديسون ،
دعا والد الدستور
إلى تعديل لإنهاء
المجمع الانتخابي في
الواقع  تم استهدافهم بالإصلاح أو
الإلغاء
حوالي 700 مرة وفقًا لمؤلف جيسي ويجمان
مؤلف
السماح للناس باختيار الرئيس
مؤخرًا  1969 -
تم تمرير تعديل دستوري لإنهاء المجمع الانتخابي بأغلبية ساحقة
في المجلس
قبل أن يتم تعطيله من قبل دعاة
الفصل العنصري في مجلس الشيوخ
، ولأن هناك تغريدة لكل
شيء حتى أن ترامب انتقد المجمع
الانتخابي باعتباره
كارثة على الديمقراطية ولكن
محاولات ترامب الحالية لقلب إرادة
يمثل الناس
شيئًا أكثر تشاؤمًا
وشرًا من مجرد أخلاقيات ظرفية
بعد أن رفضت المحكمة العليا بالإجماع
ليس واحدًا
من حججه الخالية من الحقائق بل اثنتين حتى
الجمهوريين الذين قاوموا الاعتراف
ببايدن كرئيس منتخب ، قالوا إن
تصويت الهيئة الانتخابية سيكون
حاسمًا هنا  ميتش
ماكونيل أريد أن أهنئ بشكل خاص
الرئيس المنتخب ترامب ،
أنا آسف لأنه يهنئ
دونالد ترامب في اليوم التالي لانتخابات 2016
هنا ماكونيل اليوم
في مرحلة ما هنا سنكتشف
أخيرًا
من حصل على الشهادة في كل من هذه
الولايات والانتخابات
ستحدد الكلية الفائز نعم ولكن بعض
المزيفة  يخطط المحافظون
الدستوريون لاتخاذ مزيد من التآمر
لمنع تأكيد
تصويت الهيئة الانتخابية عندما يأتي قبل
الكونجرس في 6 يناير ،
فقط تخيل ماذا سيقولون إذا
حاول الديمقراطيون هذه الحيلة
الانتظار مع حفنة من
الأصوات الاحتجاجية بعد جورج دبليو.
خسر بوش وترامب التصويت الشعبي لكنهما
فازا بالرئاسة ، لكن هذا هو الشيء الذي
لن
يوقع عليه أي
سيناتور ديمقراطي واحد ، ثم نواب الرئيس الديمقراطيين
بما في ذلك آل غور الذي ترأس
هزيمته وشاهد جو بايدن
الانتقال السلمي للسلطة
للأسف نحن  لا يمكن أن نأخذ نفس
الشعور بالمسؤولية المدنية
كأمر مسلم به ،
كل هذا مجرد دليل إضافي على سبب
حاجتنا إلى تعزيز قضبان حماية الديمقراطية
للمضي قدمًا
، ولهذا السبب اكتسبت مبادرة تُعرف باسم
الميثاق الوطني للتصويت الشعبي بين الولايات
زخمًا
مع 15 ولاية ومنطقة  من
كولومبيا تدعم خطة لمنح
ناخبيها للفائز في
التصويت
الشعبي حرب ترامب على العرض  القرصنة والآن المجمع
الانتخابي
يعكس الكثير من عدم ارتياح الجمهوريين
لحكم الأغلبية ،
نحتاج إلى إعادة تأكيد هذا
المبدأ الأساسي بقوانين ليس فقط
القواعد التي تعكس أفضل نوايا المؤسس
لأنه
كما كتب ألكسندر هاميلتون ذات مرة فإن
المبدأ الأساسي للحكومة الجمهورية
يتطلب إحساس الأغلبية  يجب أن تسود